hi my name is grace helbig if you got no
now you know your life is different now
YouTube is a no I've been making videos
on YouTube for over 10 years and the
landscape of YouTube is changing it's
sometimes for creators oftentimes for
creators hard to keep up I you have
probably noticed have dipped out of
making as many videos as I used to
because I just don't know where I fit in
I feel a little overwhelmed I feel a
little confused as to how I want to
create content so I thought these are
the types of videos that it seems like
people are watching way more on YouTube
these days so I I'm gonna try my hand at
them squat squat squat squat squat squat
squat oh man
squat squat quad my back here we go
alright squat why aren't you being more
like Ryland aren't you being cuter do
something better squad one slide okay
its quad you're eating so I caught you
at a time that makes sense for us to
talk only time we talk is about about to
eat having eaten waiting for food or
just recently digested so we are ready
squat squat squat
can you just giggle it a high pitch
that's why got it no such [ __ ] Oh squad
we tried to doing squat adventures I
have the squad is fighting right now
we're fighting this is like real real
world like real er real world so
subscribe to that because this is realer
than the real world there's I know what
you need we try to go to adventures that
didn't work and know what you need I got
it hold on oh that's the sound of
someone that wants some good skies
[Music]
why that's DIY some Gucci slides become
a thing that I watch many youtubers
desire by we're make fun of but still
yet pay money to wear do not enjoy the
actual day-to-day comfort level of them
still paid money for them still promote
them in a weird way that's what the
actual look when I was in high school I
bought adidas sandals which are exactly
like these Gucci slides and everyone
swear and they were like forty dollars
and that what luxury to me these Gucci
there are eleven hundred and fifty
dollars one hundred and you know we're
gonna keep up the things that you to
promote we're gonna hit a million
subscribers and I told her she needed to
splurge she's been looking at these
Gucci slides for literally people
wearing these kind of shoes and talking
about buying these kind of shoes
so let's DIY some Gucci slides super
quickly I have these slippers isotoners
spare no expense I know sorry
unrelatable how expensive these are
Kohl's 40% off maybe if you're lucky
good luck gonna take these and turn them
into some Gucci slides I have this
silver paper you don't want these to
look stupid I don't want these to be
dumb or uncomfortable impractical by any
means I want to get my eleven hundred
and fifty dollars worth of
Gucci slide yes so one of my squad
members curse has no idea that I got her
Gucci slides she is knowing if you got
where okay okay I've never done anything
like this I've never she's over there
and she's listening to me describe this
so hum pretend she's not there I'm going
to set this up we're gonna pretend like
this is a real thing everyone shut the
goose can you wait can you wait I had to
set the lights up
okay well in the other yeah usually go
on the other room okay hang here is wait
stay hey you wanna have a good
connection with me I don't have a camera
man so hold on $1,150 $1,150 Oh a print
this is emotional for parentheses
emotional parentheses emotional this
he's emotional guys I had no idea that
she'd have this kind of reaction
Oh parentheses emotional she can't she
can't she won't even touch him hey guys
I don't know what date is of the week I
keep forgetting um but I'll put a cute
little thing right down there
uh oh my god this week has been insane I
have new merge coming out that I I mean
you guys saw Oh
oh my god I just feel samples of a new
merge and it's a noble name Oh
oh my god you guys know me cuz you don't
know me you've never met face to face
but like you know me oh my god if you
know me then you know I like wearing
clothes clothes that I make money off of
selling to you guys so oh my
I've been working forever on these
designs Oh cannot wait for you to see
them they're gonna look like a lot of
other shirts that you've seen or clothes
that you've seen but like I put my blood
sweat and tears behind it I can't even
hold my camera to the angle where I can
see my face squad squad hey do you want
a summer bot
aks summer body not a summer like we
haven't had a conversation before the
camera turned on ya goose a also do you
want a summer bot how do I get it
this fun fit fab five minutes summer
workout let's do it in five seconds oh
it hurts my own workout hurts me it's
not hurt you Oh 12 13 17 planks well if
you do that you did that
hi guys it's me and welcome back to my
video where I try to put haha I have a
friend off-camera that is equally as
broken as me they're gonna help me place
blame on a system that helped me get
where I am but left no doubt myself as a
role model
even though deeply don't believe that in
myself oh [ __ ] I'm gonna tell you some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] that has affected me
permanently but I'm gonna say in a
really funny tone with all my friends
off-camera they're gonna laugh at it and
we're all gonna think it's funny and not
that it has affected me completely for
the rest of my life haha Wow I thought I
did great 10 million views across the
board let me know in the comments down
below what to the video you want me to
try to make in the future and let me
know in the comments down below if you
if you feel good if you if you watch a
YouTube video you feel whole and good
and like it's helping your like like let
me know in the comments down below
if you watch a YouTube video and you you
feel genuine like you feel like everyone
involved is genuinely make like let me
know in the comments down below if you
watched youtube video and you think that
you you genuinely like you like used
like let me know in the comments down
below if you genuinely have a connection
to a person and I don't know okay squat
squat squat squat squat squat
where's goose your my foot squad so have
to literally just choose one of the
Spice Girls kind of personalities and
then like make it more bland than that
come on okay do you want to be the one
that laughs that really does all the
background work you do want to be the
cute one or do you want to be like I'm
the one that you're like well that one's
kind of like cause trouble or if you
want to be the one that's just added so
that the other people feel comfortable